bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono farisei oggi siamo
nel mio fido destriero prima di arrivare
a casa mia devo fare solo uno step per
recuperare le mie chiavi di casa che ho
lasciato in custodia a un losco figuro
che poi conoscete come lorenzo vodafone
ragazzi ha finalmente ultimato la mia
gaming room
io sono veramente euforico o un mix di
emozioni che non saprei descrivere
perché passo dal curiosissimo al
felicissimo al impaurito perché
veramente non fosse il divano e lo
faranno rosa oppure se mi hanno messo
l'asse del bate riscaldata che era la
cosa più importante del suo vado a
recuperare le chiavi
let's go
[Musica]
le chiavi amico mio
parcheggi questo cassone se sei gay
poi visto che ho fatto le cose in grande
e cerca merano incen con van sai per
rendere tutti gli anni del bar del
valico in i parcheggi andiamo a casa tua
in banca ok che non ti fidi che non
l'hai capito lei non sarà anche
parcheggiare cos'ha fatto
e allora guarda è la magia tamponato
tamponato no no mafia day 20 all'ora in
macchina dove effetto vedo che hai
capito
e visto il riconoscimento facciale per
perché c'è una scusa ma non ti
preoccupare che bella giornata è l'avevo
capito questo io sono super preso bene
per te come ti senti dopo un mese che fa
il giro ma allora sono stato un mese è
qualcosa a fare il nomade quindi non so
veramente dove che cosa stiamo facendo e
dove son finito
entriamo zio entriamo anzi vela godrete
perché non entreremo così facilmente
tava
lorenzo amore di miu miu tornato a casa
tua
321 by ma dai due ore ma dai è un
infamata lo sapevo che c'era qualcosa si
matto e la porta io non è bellissima il
portello di una navicella questo questo
è il beli va già bene così
va bene ma lo cascio un cabinato tra
l'altro è un cabinato è dotato adesso
c'erano cabinato li puoi schiacciare
questo tasto per un tasto di accensione
allora date vernio arriviamo un
pezzettino per personal bevi
conquistarti la tua casa pensava nuova
strana si mettono faccio il rosso il
riordino tante completata in italia
inizia ad accendere pensa se prende una
scossa ma è bellissimo orgoglio ma se mi
bhatti puoi andare avanti se non mi va
ti dobbiamo giocare senza i dibatti noi
giochiamo
ho fatto tutto fi madonna sta piazzando
farine per bene anche ibrahimovic in
mente cosa fai
questa roba via a cos'è sabotaggio
totale e non so come fare schifo arti
andata anche bene ea chiocchio occhio
che arriva o chiariva hai scelto il
gioco dove fai più schifo cioè non ho
mai visto giocare male anch'io a 6 anni
gioco continua che continua e basta
prendere a casa
adesso no perché non si può vedere casa
mia normale ma andiamo nel cabina dove
chi si uno scalino in casa mia e
l'altare il 30 visto che devo
parcheggiare
ok siediti conosco casa mia dove diavolo
sono acconce non è possibile c'è una
stanza che non c'era quindi poi partire
il video e usa penso che non usi mai una
penna è un pezzo di carta ma provaci
perché ci saranno delle parole che ci
saranno molto utili per poi andare
avanti per entrare nell ultima per la
tua sorella
per entrare entrare la chiave la chiave
chiave avete l'hotel vogliamo sta roba
cercava jobs casa catalago promiscua
breve allora metti insieme la frase ho
compilato st fare a fondo stanza è
nascosta nell'ultima per entrare la
chiave cerca l'a321 via raga assurda sta
roba
anche questo e io me lo ricordo che
siamo alcune cose me le ricordo cosa ho
fatto cioè che la stan la chiave nella
stanza dove cercarla qua dentro che equa
acqua acqua fuoco che velino tiepidino
ok ma nella delorean della tua camera
chi stare non lo so la playstation non
nobis scacchi sono un bel pezzo è però
quale sia la verità che sono intascato
ma si parla ma siete matti
no no cosa ti ricorda elice c'è l'angolo
e vodafone dentro la libreria e questo è
comunque ragazzi questo avete scelto voi
perché quando vi ho chiesto cosa
mettiamo è detto quindi grazie leo messi
in competizione con una roba che non
aveva sede la plata appostavano nei 200
e posso prego pozzo tempio
no non può essere vero questo palazzo
la sera
ma come ci sono i miei cuffie e visto
che la poltrona richiamata l'ho fatta
con le mie mani
magari ci sto male
questo è un mappamondo che con il tuo
riconoscimento facciale si apre posso
chiedervi cosa cavolo è st
è un personal computer
sì ma se oggi bene limited edition ma se
io sono informatico e non lo so non ho
capito come mai però in un computer ci
sono delle merendine
vorrei far notare la chicca no scusate
c'è un amerindi come fa a essere un
computer prince no no no no è sempre
l'ora di fare beretta nemmeno tony stark
nell'armatura cia sta roba
wow lo sai un'altra cosa che non ha toni
star la serie la gaming
c'è un'altra cosa che lui non ha
partiamo dal bagno gabinetto con la
tavoletta riscaldata
[Musica]